Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Muriel de Meo
Sapete quello che si dice,
che le coppie si compensano?
Io penso che sia davvero così.
Vedete, mio marito
è una persona straordinaria.
Solo che ha quella particolare abitudine
di fare le cose all'ultimo minuto.
Lui fa sempre le cose all'ultimo minuto,
sia che debba preparare le valigie
per andare in vacanza,
o debba accompagnarmi da qualche parte
sapendo che devo arrivare in orario.
E la cosa, ovviamente,
mi fa saltare i nervi
perché io sono l'esatto opposto,
sono una pianificatrice,
ho tutto organizzato molto tempo prima
nella mia agenda on line.
E odio, odio veramente
arrivare in ritardo.
Ogni tanto, penso che il problema
sia che sono un ingegnere:
e gli ingegneri, di solito,
sono persone molto organizzate.
Ma è naturale,
perché abbiamo a che fare con oggetti
che devono durare a lungo.
Non possiamo fare le cose
all'ultimo minuto.
Ma come fanno gli ingegneri
a progettare qualcosa oggi,
sicuri che funzionerà a lungo?
Non basta organizzare bene
la propria agenda, giusto?
Parliamo, ad esempio,
del sistema di trasporto.
Diciamo che progettate un ponte oggi,
e lo costruite nei prossimi tre anni.
E questa struttura deve durare
per i prossimi 100 anni.
Sembra incredibile, ma è la normalità
per qualsiasi ingegnere.
E allora, come si fa
a progettare qualcosa oggi
ed essere sicuri che funzionerà
per 50, 100 anni?
Abbiamo una vaga idea dei requisiti futuri
del sistema di trasporto?
Perché se progetto una strada oggi,
devo decidere oggi
che quella strada sarà larga
un certo numero di metri.
E non posso che basarmi sui requisiti
del sistema di trasporto di oggi.
Ma come possiamo essere sicuri
che soddisfi anche i requisiti
del sistema di trasporto del futuro?
La storia è lì a dimostrare
che non è sempre andata così.
E allora come fanno gli ingegneri
a progettare le loro strutture
sicuri che funzioneranno tanto a lungo?
Abbiamo anche solo un'idea
di come si trasformerà, in futuro,
il sistema di trasporto?
Macchine elettriche?
Magari neanche più esisteranno,
le auto di proprietà.
Magari ci sposteremo in treni superveloci,
che sfrecceranno in tunnel nascosti.
E questo potrebbe accadere
in un futuro non così lontano.
E allora come si fa
a progettare, oggi, qualcosa
ed essere sicuri che funzioni
per tutto questo tempo?
La Norvegia ha colto
questa particolare sfida.
Questa che vedete è la E39.
È una strada europea
che corre per 1.100 km,
lungo la costa ovest della Norvegia.
E per percorrerla tutta, oggi,
da Kristiansand a sud della Norvegia
fino a Trondheim, a metà della Norvegia,
dove la E39 finisce,
in macchina ci vogliono 21 ore.
Questo tempo di percorrenza
è dovuto principalmente
ai sette passaggi via mare,
che a tutt'oggi si possono attraversare
soltanto con dei traghetti.
Pensiamoci un attimo.
Ci sono delle zone, lungo la E39,
in cui dovete prendervi ben tre ore
per raggiungere l'ospedale più vicino.
Tre ore!
Ok, se avete un'emergenza
potete affidarvi agli elicotteri -
se il tempo ve lo permette.
I norvegesi che vivono
lungo la E39, quindi,
sono i più sani del paese -
o quantomeno i più fortunati.
Sto scherzando, naturalmente.
Ma in quella zona vive
un terzo della popolazione norvegese;
e più del 50 percento
dell'export nazionale
si produce in quell'area.
Questo dimostra l'enorme potenziale
di quella regione.
Però questo potenziale richiede persone;
e queste persone richiedono servizi.
Devono raggiungere i posti di lavoro,
gli ospedali, le scuole.
Hanno bisogno di un sistema di trasporto
efficiente e affidabile.
Senza un sistema di trasporto
siamo delle isole,
e nessuno vuole vivere isolato.
Ecco perché la gente si sposta,
abbandonando le zone rurali
e spostandosi nelle città.
Da cui la necessità di una viabilità
efficiente e affidabile
lungo la E39 in Norvegia.
E dei traghetti cosa ce ne facciamo?
Dovete sapere che in Norvegia,
quando le persone pensano ai traghetti
di norma pensano agli sveler
che mangiano sui traghetti.
Cosa sono gli sveler?
Allora gli sveler sono -
ok, sono una sorta di pancake,
scusate se ci sono norvegesi in sala.
Ok: se devo dirla tutta,
i norvegesi pensano
che gli sveler migliori
sono quelli che si mangiano
al bar del traghetto.
Ecco perché i norvegesi
non li abbandoneranno mai.
Esagero, ok:
però i traghetti sono un modo,
per gli autisti, di fare una pausa.
Sono un'attrazione turistica nazionale,
fanno parte della cultura norvegese.
Sicuramente, quindi,
i traghetti rimarranno.
Magari saranno, ad esempio,
traghetti elettrici.
La mobilità futura, però,
di certo non potrà contare su di loro.
E non solo per la disponibilità
quando dovete fare la traversata;
ma anche per l'impatto enorme
che le navi hanno sull'ambiente.
Parliamo di ambiente.
Meno traghetti e più ponti,
più attraversamenti fissi
possono essere un modo
per ridurre l'impatto sulla fauna marina.
E guardate che queste sono zone
con migliaia di specie marine
che sono veramente molto preziose
dal punto di vista ambientale.
Sono anche zone di allevamento ittico,
e questa attività è considerata
il secondo petrolio norvegese.
Pensate quindi un istante all'impatto
che un incremento del rumore
sui fiordi norvegesi
potrebbe avere sull'ambiente: enorme.
E allora costruiamo qualche ponte, no?
Non è la cosa più semplice del mondo.
Alcuni di questi fiordi sono molto ampi:
fino a sei chilometri.
E anche molto profondi:
possono superare il chilometro.
Le tecnologie tradizionali
da ponte, quindi,
in questo caso non sono praticabili.
E allora che fare?
Nel 2013, il governo norvegese
ha inserito gli attraversamenti
lungo l'autostrada E39
in un documento nazionale
chiamato "Piano Nazionale dei Trasporti".
E da quel momento è iniziato
un processo molto complesso
per sviluppare nuove tecnologie
che ne permettessero l'attraversamento.
Questo ponte galleggiante, ad esempio,
potrebbe essere una delle soluzioni.
È una tecnologia già esistente,
ne esistono già in tutto il mondo,
e potrebbe fare anche al caso nostro.
Un'alternativa potrebbe essere
un'altra tipologia da ponte ben nota -
i ponti sospesi.
Ma invece di affidarsi
a delle torri tradizionali,
ci affidiamo a queste piattaforme,
queste torri galleggianti,
che sono strutture utilizzate
nell'ambito offshore.
Lo so cosa state pensando:
come fanno queste strutture
a rispettare l'ambiente circostante?
Pensiamo ad esempio alle interferenze
con i flussi migratori dei volatili.
Per alcuni di questi fiordi
questo può essere un problema.
E allora abbiamo un'alternativa:
un "ponte di Archimede".
Il Ponte di Archimede
è un ponte sommerso, ma galleggiante.
L'immersione vi permette di bilanciare
i carichi verticali della struttura,
sfruttando la spinta di Archimede
che ogni corpo immerso ha.
L'immersione vi aiuta, inoltre,
a ridurre il carico verticale,
come le onde, sulla struttura,
E questa è una differenza enorme
rispetto ai classici ponti sospesi.
che sono inevitabilmente esposti
a tutti gli elementi ambientali,
come il vento, le onde, le correnti.
Con questa struttura, inoltre,
potete realizzare un ponte nascosto.
Se scegliete l'opzione
con pontoni galleggianti,
potete realizzarli come delle isole verdi
minimizzando così
l'impatto sul paesaggio.
Però, dobbiamo dirlo,
non c'è una tipologia valida
a prescindere per tutti.
La cosa migliore
è valutare la struttura migliore
per quello specifico attraversamento.
Però c'è una cosa che potete fare
per ogni applicazione di queste strutture.
Potete progettare la strada
in modo che generi meno CO2.
Potete progettare nuove strutture
che siano più resistenti
ai carichi ambientali.
Potete andare a trovare
dei nuovi materiali,
più leggeri o magari più resistenti,
che vi permettano di progettare
strutture più sicure, o più resilienti.
Potete utilizzare le azioni
dell'ambiente attorno a voi
per creare dell'energia pulita.
Potete fare tantissime cose:
ma come si fa a fare tutto questo?
Guardate, questo è l'unico modo
per progettare per il futuro:
si chiama ricerca.
Per la sola E39 sono stati finanziati
più di 50 progetti di ricerca,
negli ultimi anni.
Progettare per il futuro si può,
se si investe in persone e in ricerca.
La ricerca vi aiuterà a elaborare
la migliore soluzione oggi disponibile
per il vostro futuro.
Crea anche delle buone prassi,
perché anche le società di consulenza
investiranno in ricerca.
Creerete lavoro per le persone
assunte nelle varie società.
Creerete una corposa
comunità internazionale,
che investirà in giovani professionisti
provenienti da tutto il mondo.
Insomma, creerete crescita,
a tantissimi livelli.
Dopo le pubblicazioni che abbiamo fatto
per il Ponte di Archimede,
molte nazioni hanno ricominciato
a valutare questa struttura.
La Norvegia vuole ispirare il mondo.
La Norvegia vuole condividere
i risultati della sua ricerca.
Ah, dimenticavo:
questa splendida signora è una collega,
ed è la project manager
del progetto dell'E39 in Norvegia.
Vediamo se la Norvegia riesce
a ispirare altri paesi
anche su qualche altro tema.
Faccio un esempio a caso:
l'uguaglianza di genere?
Ora vi chiederete:
ma lei chi è, cosa ci fa qui?
Io sono la fan sfegatata
del Ponte di Archimede, l'avrete capito.
Sono ingegnere capo
presso l'amministrazione
pubblica norvegese,
e sono responsabile per gli studi
su questa incredibile struttura.
Mi sono spostata in Norvegia
ormai sei anni fa,
e ho visto crescere un gruppo di persone,
che lavorano su questi progetti.
Ho incontrato persone
provenienti da tutto il mondo.
Ho avuto la fortuna di studiare
alcuni degli argomenti
più interessanti per un ingegnere.
Ho avuto l'opportunità di sentirmi parte
di una comunità scientifica internazionale
che dalla Norvegia alla Corea del Sud
sta lavorando per lo stesso obiettivo.
Abbiamo visto realizzarsi
alcuni dei nostri progetti,
e devi sempre fare i conti
con chi si oppone al tuo progetto.
Discutiamo, ci arrabbiamo,
vendiamo cara la pelle.
Lottiamo per ciò in cui crediamo.
Un viaggio incredibile.
E mi sento molto fortunata
ad averne potuto far parte.
Spero davvero che un giorno
la Norvegia veda una E39
completa di tutti gli attraversamenti.
Anche se i politici, fino ad ora,
sono stati lungimiranti,
le loro priorità possono
sempre cambiare nel futuro.
Del resto, tutto può cambiare nella vita.
Però una cosa è sicura, una cosa resterà:
la conoscenza che la Norvegia ha prodotto.
Perché queste persone,
ovunque saranno nel mondo,
saranno sicuramente le persone
che potranno progettare il nostro futuro.
E voi volete progettare per il futuro?
Iniziamo a organizzare l'agenda oggi.
Perché dobbiamo investire in persone,
dobbiamo investire in ricerca.
E dobbiamo iniziare a farlo oggi.
(Applausi)